but were you the kind of guy that like
once he did a new drug like were you the
kind of guy who would get nervous about
or you're like nah give it let me try it
n or were you like like my hands are
getting clammy just [__] thinking
about doing drugs and I haven't you know
I was just very excited to try whatever
I can get cuz you shot up acid yeah and
like you weren't you weren't nervous
about no no not at all I at that point
when I when I did shoot up acid it was
my my motto was like if I could rig it I
could dig it so it's like God anything
that I could put in a needle I would and
I just it it it was really gnarly what I
didn't do it again but it was like a
hell of an experience what was it it was
just instant like you know how so it
takes a little bit of time to to kick in
when you eat it it was just snap a
finger how many doses did you take I
don't know the the mill milliliters but
it was uh you took a tab you cooked it
up and you f no no no no we had the
liquid LSD we had liquid LSD that we got
from Silk Road
silk and you bought it through Bitcoin
with Bitcoin when Bitcoin was $100 and
you wow how much is assd on the Silk
Road at that time okay wait a second so
you had Bitcoin when it was worth 100
bucks
and and what what did you sell it at um
we didn't sell we would use it to buy
drugs off office how many Bitcoin do you
think you spent oh yeah
oh dude we were spending a lot a Bitcoin
yeah a lot because we lived in the
middle of Vermont so it's like we didn't
really have drug dealers anywhere so
it's like that we would just order a
bunch of drugs and come straight to our
door Sil was just reliable as hell super
was likeon it was like Amazon five star
reviews you know if they had good
reviews you know that they wouldn't rob
you for your money what' you buy on
there everything
like give me an example of something you
bought on there heroin liquid LSD uh
powder Ed Xanax is good
bro the the stuff that I've gotten off
Silk Road was probably the best stuff
I've ever done in my life whoa no joke
yeah straight to your doorstep right but
but like let's say marijuana it just it
has a powerful smell like what do they
do about that we never ordered marijuana
I mean dude at that time I wasn't
worried about smoking weed I all my
interest was just [__] right the okay
so what so uh does heroin not have like
a a smell no I mean it does if you take
it out of the package but like if you
wrap it up pretty good so so Silk Road
had like like packing standards to make
sure
that would they put would would would
you order like a like an ounce of heroin
and it shows up in like a big gigantic
box where it's hidden in the middle no
it would uh a lot of the times it would
be in like candy packages and it would
be like a box full of different things
of candy and then like would there would
there be like a a little uh note on your
account be like it's in the
Reeses yeah yeah really yeah you weren't
worried about like the it says the FBI
shuts down Silk Road like you weren't
worried about them know you had an
account no dude I was what was your
username on there every every YouTube
video about Silk Road is just the
greatest video out there dude it was
crazy you could you could get anything
you wanted from the black market on Silk
Road it was super gnarly and wasn't it
like uh that that they promised that
they didn't keep anybody's information
but in fact they totally did and then
the FBI had like the guy's laptop with
like every single person's name and
address you see that movie on the Silk
Road I tried to watch the movie with the
actors and I just couldn't do it but uh
I watched every documentary on YouTube
see uh Vinnie how do you how didd you
log into the Silk Road what do you you
had to use a a a t a tour yeah a torrent
a torrent yeah see I was I think a
torrent is different than
T I think I I I'm not sure see I wasn't
the The Tech Guy The Tech Guy was like
my best friend he was the one that had
all the Bitcoin he was the one that do
that but he passed away did you see
things you can buy cuz I've heard you
could like hire a hit you H hit you
could H you saw all that for purchase
how much is it to like hire a hit I
don't remember I wasn't really didn't
and then the guy the Silk Road guy was
like hiring a hit I don't know he ended
up getting busted at like a a library he
ended up getting busted for trying to
hire a hit oh I don't know yeah that's
wild did sentence suis sitting there
obviously my my retention is not that
great if I watched every video about it
but like I swear I I loved every video I
watched and then like eventually when
when Silk Road got taken down they they
started Silk Road 2 and then that got
taken down and then it was a Pandora's
market and that was a big one and people
are buying drugs on like Craigslist
right so like if you need bu drug on CRA
you got to go to for hire he targeted
five people and murder for hire the guy
ended up in like a rocking a hard spot
situ situation where like if he didn't
um like draw a hard line and and kill
some people then everyone else is going
to take advantage of him yeah poor poor
guy God decision's
decision so Vinnie when people go into
like your sober living or something like
I it's crazy to me that people are
buying like heroin off Craigslist and
what they're searching for is like I
need I'm looking for a roofer For Hire
no no it's so if you're looking for
heroin it's called Roofing tar like you
search up roofing tar on Craigslist
really yeah or xanax you you uh ladders
um what yeah Ladders because ozanic Spar
looks like a little mini ladder and then
uh for crystal meth it was
a uh window window something and so what
you go to like hiring on Craigslist and
like it's called glass yeah yeah glass
yeah and uh um no you don't look not for
hire for sale in the four salees Isaac
can you do that I don't know if it's
still a thing anymore but because that's
when I was in when I first came don't do
that dude I don't need my house like
searching for no no but you're just
hiring a
painter do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Ste ste's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and sto's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude